going on everybody Ian hardik's here on
behalf of PFF welcome to BR Fantasy Live
have a fantastic start sit show on the
way for you guys today happy week 17
championship week let's go win some
fantasy football Hardware why the heck
not before we get going just wanted to
update you guys on a few injuries that
we do have going around the league
Derrick Henry has been ruled out at
least the reporters have told us that he
is going to be out after being listed as
doubtful remember nominal backup Donald
is on IR so reportedly per NFL Network's
Tom pellicero is going to be Hassan
Haskins the rookie from Michigan who
unfortunately tore many in Ohio State
Buckeyes fans heart out of our chest
last November but he could be the Saving
Grace for your fantasy season when it
gets down to week 17. so Haskins
wouldn't get completely carried away
this is still an offense implied for
about 14 or 15 points not exactly the
best offensive environment but you can
do worse than 15 20 touches and if you
are one of those managers without
Derrick Henry or Tony Paul or suddenly
you could do a lot worse than picking up
Haskins on the way wave a wire speaking
of Tony Pollard he is also not expecting
to suit up per the same guy Tom
pellicero appreciate you having those
fantasy managers at the Forefront of
your thoughts but without powering the
picture it really does bring up the
possibility to see Ezekiel Elliott with
a full-time role something that the
Cowboys and Keller Moore have been more
willing to give him in past years but as
we've seen they turn to backfield
rightfully into more of a 50 50 split
with bozique and paulers thing plenty
involved so yes the Tennessee Titans run
defense is an awfully great unit I mean
they really do just force teams to have
to go to the air because of how sound
they are against the run but the thing
is with no Pollard there that's sweet
sweet volume and a touchdown upside in
the Cowboys offense that leads the NFL
and points for games since Dak Prescott
got back from injury Ezekiel Elliott is
right there in the rb1 discussion thanks
to that injury
and with that everyone welcome to be our
Fantasy Live presented by State Farm as
I said just a few minutes ago we have a
fantastic show on the docker for you
starts and sits love seeing all you guys
in the chat already and I want to answer
as many of your questions as I can
throughout the show but first of all try
to get through a bunch of these guys
that we do throughout the year not
exactly telling you guys hey you know
start this top five running back no
matter what trying to go out on a limb
just a little bit and talk through some
of the guys that maybe you're a little
bit more uncertain about so we're gonna
kick things off with a look at the goat
himself but I am sorry Mr Tom Brady you
are a recommended sit this week we have
seen Brady and the Buccaneers get back
on track to a slight extent but even
then guys 28th and scoring this year
28th Tom Brady in the Buccaneers despite
having a fairly healthy group of weapons
I mean Goblin's been back since week
four Mike Evans has been there Lenny
fournette playing through the pain so I
know losing a b and losing Gronk I
didn't expect them to repeat as a number
two ranked scoring offense from last
year 28th is just a fall that I don't
think anybody saw coming so with Brady
at this point he's just not someone that
we can trust in this offense and
honestly Chris Goblin and to a lesser
extent Leonard fournette are the only
guys that we can you take away old-time
BFF Rob Gronkowski and you have Mike
Evans all of a sudden allergic to the
end zone 11 straight games without a
touchdown from Mike Evans in 2020 2021
including playoffs he never went more
than two games without scoring a
touchdown with all this said Tom Brady
is my qb14 on the week behind guys like
Geno Smith Kirk Cousins Mike White
Gardner minshu and more as I said before
love all you guys hanging out with us in
the chat from wlvs VZ you know lost Tony
Pollard should I go with moss or
Robinson so with Brian Robinson we
actually could see Antonio Gibson out of
the picture and in that case I would
bump him up enough to have him as the
preferred pick over Zack Moss otherwise
go ahead and give me Moss we have seen
him now play over 70 percent of the
snaps in back to back weeks and it was
is especially important last week
because it also included Jordan Wilkins
being active so if we get no Antonio
Gibson give me Brian Robinson otherwise
Zach Moss
from Mr penchy need a second quarterback
for superflex Stidham or at Teddy
Bridgewater never Jared Stidham that's
the answer to that one but in all
seriousness Teddy Bridgewater the guy
knows how to freaking cover spreads and
he's also been a somewhat decent fantasy
QB over the years at least when he's
surrounded with high quality weapons
like he is right now with Tyreek Hill
and Jalen waddle so give me Teddy good
luck my friend let's get to a positive
thing a start here at the quarterback
position minshu Mania himself Gardner
minshu Philadelphia Eagles qb1 probably
for another week we did get Jalen hurts
back at practice today in a limited
capacity but judging for some of the
reports there you know wasn't even
participating in some of the drills
where they're trying to knock out the
fumble and all that so still seems like
they're being careful with hurts and as
much as it's nice seeing him back at
practice most recent reports have
indicated that it's going to be until
the playoffs that we see Jalen hurt
suiting up once again so with minshu now
we've had three starts over these past
two seasons and he's ripped off two top
10 fantasy finishes and why not could
you pick a better offense in the NFL in
terms of just overall surrounding
support and casts I cannot and honestly
the analytics tell us that that is the
case I took every single team's PFF
rushing receiving pass blocking and run
blocking grade basically everything
except passing which obviously is
controlled by the quarterback nobody has
been better than the Philadelphia Eagles
this season in terms of that surrounding
cast so AJ Brown Devonte Smith a healthy
Dallas Goddard hopefully a run game
that's featuring a better version of
Miles Sanders Gardner minshu is coming
out as my qb9 on the week ahead of guys
like Aaron Rodgers Mike White Kirk
Cousins and more
from Tua in the chat welcome to a man
hope that head's feeling better is
Dodson a must start I wouldn't say a
must start when we have Carson Wentz
under Center it really has changed the
dynamic of this Washington Commander's
offense if you look at the first six
weeks of the Season Curtis Samuel had I
believe 10 additional targets then Terry
McLaurin during that stretch so I'm not
saying once as you know Mr great
decision maker with the football in his
hands or anything like that but nobody
is worse than Taylor heinecke in terms
of worthy plays he has much more of a
gunslinger mindset I mean I kind of
equate Taylor heinecke to like a Patrick
Mahomes decide to play every single game
left-handed so honestly like I don't
think he makes the wrong read a lot of
times but the problem is he don't think
he has the arm strength to live up to
what his brain is always trying to do so
with Wenz I think Curtis Samuel actually
leaves him to be the number two wide
receiver behind Terry McLaren dots him
over Boomer bus wide receiver four who
doesn't need to be a must start under
any circumstances and finally juliannaga
Gabe Davis or Johanna Dotson I'm gonna
go with Gabriel Davis here I know it's
been a kind of up and down season with
more busts than booms and and as number
number two receiver in a Josh Allen LED
offense we would hope for a bigger
overall counting stats but if there was
a game to think Gabriel Davis and all
these complimentary receivers in Buffalo
could really get going more than usual
why not an absolute shootout on Monday
night football against Joe Burl in those
Cincinnati Bengals so Gabe Davis Jahan
Dotson I think they have similar you
know Target projections in this one give
me the guy catching balls from Josh
Allen in the overall more high scoring
matchup
all right guys another start before
you're moving on to some running backs
now hasn't been the greatest stretch run
here but the usage is still there I'm
confident that we could finally get that
boom we've been waiting for Travis etn
you know the Jaguars second year running
back after unfortunately he was robbed
of his rookie season with that foot
injury so with etn coming back from
another foot injury he suffered this
year four straight games with at least
70 touches and they've been very much
down to feed him the ball I mean in
those performances 16 17 21 and 25
touches in those games yeah it'd be a
lot cooler if they threw in the ball a
little bit more but it's really tough to
complain about that sort of volume
especially when we got it coming up now
against the Houston Texans League ores
defense and PPR points per game allowed
to opposing running backs so with etn
and the rest the Jaguar starters for
that matter you do have to be somewhat
concerned about if they're still going
to be going full speed this week because
as we know really this AFC South is
coming down to Titans Jaguars in week 18
not a team has much of anything to play
for this week luckily our guide Doug
Peterson has already come out in the
press conference come out and said that
he has absolutely no intentions of
resting any of these guys so we got
Doug's word we've seen the usage we know
etn I mean my goodness guys you watched
him with the ball in his hands it's like
he's got you know a full-time power up
and you know I I would say a full-time
golden mushroom you know going back to
our Mario Kart days dude is absolutely
electric out there he is my rb13 on the
week ahead of guys like Kenneth Walker
cam Akers Jared McKinnon Leonard
fournette Alvin Kamara who I just don't
think have as good of a matchup and
we're talking about very similar if not
better volume for a guy like Travis etm
keep it coming in the chat guys
appreciate you each and every week here
on BR Fantasy Live from bologna 24 Brock
Purdy or Gardner minshu I'm gonna be
rolling with minshu here I mean the
thing with Purdy I believe he has like
11 carries for 19 yards it's something
horrific but he is an absolute zero in
the Run game and whatever they have
Christian McCaffrey and George Kittle
and Brandon I have plenty of guys that
can get the ball to and not rely on
Brock Purdy's Wheels but with minshu I
think the passing numbers are in our
situation where we can say maybe those
are pretty equal two guys in offenses
where again places to go all over the
place with the football but when you do
have menshu and the biggest cheat code
that I've seen in the NFL this season
and that being those Philadelphia Eagles
QB sneaks I like the chances of minshu
finding finding Peter on the ground give
me minchu over pretty just by a few
spots though good problem to have from
empanadas for Life great freaking
username man is Malik Davis worth the
start absolutely not I mean okay if
you're really desperate we're talking 14
Team league three flexes and it's
between him and like 2-2 Atwell okay
then maybe Malik Davis with Tony Pollard
not expecting to play but more than
anything guys I think Ezekiel Elliott
being healthy I mean let's remember he's
played a good six seven games now since
originally suffering that knee injury
being healthy being so in the good
graces of the Cowboys I mean come on
obviously Tony Pollard's had a fantastic
season in his own right but Zeke's
pretty pretty damn good too has not
finished outside of the of the top 20
weekly running backs and four people are
scoring since week five so I really
think we could see a situation where
unless the Cowboys completely blow out
the Titans which is possible I don't
think Malik's getting more than three or
five touches in this one
all right guys another running back that
we're feeling good about and we are
going to be recommending him as a start
Falcons new rb1 Tyler algier and this
pains me guys if you go to my Twitter
I'm in the long time president of the
Cordero Patterson fan club and cpat is
still a freaking King best kick returner
of all time for my money's worth but
with algier he's been pretty pretty
awesome in his own right pick a stat any
stat this could tell you he's one of the
League's most efficient running backs so
out of a study 100 plus carries with the
running backs you know we have 44
qualified running backs this year that
fit that he is seventh in PFF Russian
grid tie for seventh in Euros per carry
tied for 16 yards after contact for
Kerry and tied for Fifth and Miss
tackles Force per carries so yeah they
don't throw the ball too much to their
running backs in Atlanta they don't
throw the ball much to anyone in Atlanta
but that being said we now have the Bell
cow back with a nice usage change in
week 16 really turning over the
backfield to him and a match up against
the Cardinals where it's just not
something that we should be concerned
about 30th ranked defense and scoring on
the season I was here is my rb18 ahead
of guys like Alvin Kamara both Packers
running backs miles Sanders and Naji
Harris
from Teo the god Swift DJ Moore or AJ
Dylan I'm gonna have to go with AJ Dylan
in that conversation so the whole Aaron
Jones thing has been very tough to get a
read on last week he sets season low
marks and touches and snap rates uh you
know just at least compared to his other
games where he wasn't actively injured
in but we don't even know what actively
injured means anymore for him in Green
Bay knee ankle Shin glute injuries one
issue after another for Jones and down
the stretch they've been more willing to
than ever to just turn the backfield
more and more over to AJ Dylan he's
outscored Aaron Jones two times over the
last four weeks so DJ Moore has been
finding the end zone three of his last
four games here with Sam darnold under
Center but actually averaging fewer
targets per game than he was at Baker
and PJ Walker so just not enough volume
for there give me AJ Dylan
and from Syria what do you think of
Herbert this week Khalil Herbert I have
no interest in playing just didn't see
enough users behind Dave Montgomery
you're probably talking about Justin
Herbert and in that case guys I think
we're looking at someone that continues
to make great plays as long as he has
all of his Playmakers healthy which at
this point this season they do so God
always remember when we're talking about
Justin Herbert like you know he suffered
that rib injury back in what week two
week three and I can't imagine that's
something easy to play through and
accordingly we haven't seen him give us
look not like Justin Herbert was going
to be putting up Justin fields or Lamar
Jackson rushing yards but really been
more of a zero in that then uh you know
we could even remember but Justin
Herbert for me still my qb5 in this spot
only guys I would start ahead of him Joe
burrow Justin Fields Josh Allen and
Patrick Mahomes and from bendu Devin
Hester is way better kick returns Devin
Hester is the king punt returner cpat
he's got the record for kick return
touchdowns don't shoot the messenger
hey I'm the president of the fan club
all right you got to give my guy cpat
some love but yes Devin Hester a king in
his own right all right guys I do have a
sit here and it's going to be someone
that I do think is playing better as the
season goes on but unfortunately we're
not getting the volume we need to
recommend him as a start Baltimore
Ravens running back J.K Dobbins and the
troubling thing with Dobbins is
they even went ahead and asked his head
coach uh John Harbaugh what he actually
thinks about Dobbins and Gus Edwards are
they still being limited by these
injuries they're coming back from and
the answer was no they're not this is
just what the Ravens and Greg Roman want
to do and that's used not one not two
but three different running backs
Justice Hill and Kenyan Drake not So
Much Drake in recent weeks but those
guys have mattered ultimately in these
three games back with both Edwards and
Dobbins in the picture we've actually
seen Justice Hill and Drake out Target
those two two ones so with Dobbins to
one of those things where you're just
relying on him to make the most out of
12 to 15 touches per game that are all
going to be on the ground and it's
unfortunately an offense without the
same sort of scoring upside with Lamar
Jackson not looking all that luckily to
return this week so again with Dobbins
these three games back 15 14 12 touches
the snap rates 43 38 42 percent it's
honestly what they used to do before he
even suffered the injury in 2021
unfortunately he's not averaging the six
yards per carry this year that he did
back in 2020 to make things a bit easier
so JK Dobbins don't hate the player hate
the usage I hate his usage he's just the
rb25 on the week for me behind guys like
Naji Harris miles Sanders both Packers
running backs
I also want to quickly go through
another sit at the running back position
someone that gave us some really good
weeks here within the last month or two
but just I think we've seen this
backfield go over more so to the team's
week one starter and early season
Workhorse that's going to be Rashad
white of the Tampa Bay Buccaneers and a
lot of the things I said about Tom Brady
and the overall offensive environment
apply here 28th in scoring so we're not
kidding a team that's going to be giving
us a bunch of excess Boom games with the
points flying all over the place one
time one time all season this offense
has scored more than 23 points in a game
truly just a maddening you know
situation and for Byron Leftwich to come
out a couple weeks ago saying uh we're
not playing fantasy football here we're
worried about real life that's an insult
because when Arthur Smith said that
earlier in the year hey at least he was
talking about you know a top 10 scoring
offense and they're winning games
putting up 30 plus points and afterwards
when people were asking about Kyle Pitts
usage it's like who cares we're scoring
points we're winning games like I don't
care about fantasy football that I can
get but for Byron Leftwich notice steal
his flow there didn't even make sense
for him to do it so unfortunately with
shop white again the bigger issue is the
offensive environment and just Leonard
fournette coming on strong any Leonard
fournette fantasy managers out there I
mean it's been probably would have been
better off this season not watching
those games not going through you know
the pain just on an every Drive basis
but it's one of those players where you
look up at the end of the season and my
goodness guys top 12 running back on a
per game and overall basis in full PPR
scoring so that's kind of been the
Allure for fournette and and or shop
white this season it's it's if you only
feature one of them we're in an offense
that throws the ball to his running
backs more than anyone outside the Los
Angeles Chargers and Austin Eckler
unfortunately unfortunately for a shop
white that guy right now is Leonard
fournette and it really isn't as big of
a difference between the two
efficiency-wise as a lot of people make
it out to be I mean when we look at Zeke
versus Paul or even Dave Montgomery and
Khalil Herbert you start looking at the
yards per carrying some metrics like
that and all of a sudden it's like yeah
why isn't the backup getting out there
more I mean he is just killing it I mean
neither of these Tampa Bay running backs
are averaging over four yards per carry
we've routinely see fournette be a great
pass protect be great in pass protection
even going back all the way to week one
when he sent Michael Parsons Straight to
Hell and just yards per route run also
something that fournette leads in so
Rashad white has always been one of the
top handcuffs in fantasy and we even saw
him carve out a nice little 50 50 roll
there for a while all signs pointed to
fournette though down the stretch so I
want nothing to do with white
all right chat rugger lost Tua Mike
White or Brock Purdy I'm gonna have to
be riding with Mike White I do think the
idea of him you know taking over for uh
the Jets in the long term is a little
bit over you know blown but the only
thing with Brock Purdy yes he has
multiple touchdown passes and all four
of his extended appearances but we've
seen the Shanahan offense and we've seen
what they want to do let's run the ball
and just get the ball in the hands of
their Playmakers I don't think he has
the same sort of 40 45 pass attempt
upside that someone like Mike White does
so with the Jets I understand that it's
not exactly a layup matchup against the
Seahawks team still you know fighting
for their right to hopefully make the
playoffs but that said guys not a
secondary that I'm absolutely terrified
of and Tariq Wooley the number one
cornerback doesn't Shadow so Garrett
Wilson Mike White two guys I would
recommend starting this week and from
Tinseltown Haskins or Deontay Foreman
that's a pretty tough one man you guys
have given me some tough start assists
today as championship week though isn't
that what it's all about so I have
Foreman as my rb26 right now and
honestly right next to him is going to
be Hassan Haskins kind of funny it's
breaking down this way because Haskins
is basically this year's Deontay Foreman
Foreman as we remember last year was
taken over most of the work when Derrick
Henry got injured in the first place
I am gonna lean towards Deontay Foreman
though as nice of a report as it was
from Tom pellicero that we're going to
see a big role for Hassan Haskins still
a bit of a guessing game I wouldn't be
surprised at all if Julius Chestnut is
also going to be heavily involved and
the situation in Tennessee could be
absolutely dismal again Vegas projecting
this offense to score I believe a week
low and imply points I'll take the ante
foreman and a Panthers offense that has
been with Sam Donald under Center guys
easily the most run-heavy group in the
league I'm just more confident informing
getting 15 plus touches and I think the
Carolina Panthers offense as a whole is
set up better in the titans this week
all right guys moving on to some wide
receivers and tight ends before we get
to all of your start sick questions
again keep sending those in the chat but
Drake London someone that we uh honestly
were not too happy about to start the
season with he is now going to be a
recommended start for me when it matters
most we've now gotten four games without
Kyle Pitts in the fold and yeah the
first one was a dud just a wide receiver
76 finish for London and four PPR
scoring but since then wide receiver 20
wide receiver 26 and wide receiver 14
actually with good Target volume and
we're not talking about these four
Target games where he just made the most
out of it 12 11 and 9 targets for Drake
London so there have not been many read
any guys that we could have any sort of
you know pass game efficiency pass game
consistency I should say going on in
Atlanta this year Drake London better
late than never starting to get there
with Desmond Ritter under Center so with
London again zero games with even 50
plus receiving yards in weeks 4 through
12. I get it if you use a high pick on
the guy maybe he's not even in a
position to help save your non
Championship Squad in the first place
but that said if you do have Drake
London he's my wide receiver 27 on the
week ahead of guys like Deontay Johnson
Michael Pittman Gabe Davis Zay Jones and
more also another start I'm going to
have here is going to be Noah fan of the
Seattle Seahawks tight M1 now that will
dissly in his big time paycheck Big Time
off-season payday is on IR to end the
season so with Noah fan former first
round tight end as you guys can see with
our nice little sunglasses graphic here
guys always rocking the visor guys got
some swag guy can make some big plays
after the catch which I think he's going
to be asking more than ever against the
Jets defense that arguably has the two
best pairs of outside cornerbacks in the
entire league so while DK Metcalf and if
he plays Tyler Lockett could have a
tough times with those cornerbacks I
think Noah fan could be leaned on more
than ever both because of will Disney
being out and also because this is the
easiest way to attack a very Stout jet
secondary so maybe Geno Smith Rises to
the occasion in that Revenge game no
offense this week's take some Hill for
me in terms of being in my top
recommended ad on the way for Wired to
go sure up that tight end spot so he's
my Titan 11 on the week I would start
know a fan ahead of guys like taysom
Hill call Matt darum Waller and Gerald
Everett a couple more chat questions
before we finish things out here Andrew
Woodburn
needs to start too what are you doing
putting Austin that clone to start sick
question so you need to start one
between miles Sanders David Montgomery
or Cam Acres that's a decent question I
am going to go with David Montgomery
here now we saw this lions run defense
really improve a lot during the second
half of the Season until they allow 320
rushing yards the Carolina Panthers so
with David Montgomery even with Khalil
Herbert back and even when Khalil
Herbert was back earlier in the year the
Bears have found a way to get him 15
plus touches I believe in all but one
game this season so Bears Lions has the
highest combined game total on the week
and wow Justin fields and Khalil Herbert
are also threats to you know take some
of that share in the Russian game Dave
Montgomery continues to be that
Workhorse in Chicago so versus those
other two give me Herbert I'm sorry give
me David Montgomery and yes Austin
Ackerman Colin Fury DJ Moore Greg
dulcich or Tyler Boyd in full PPR I'm
gonna have to go with DJ Moore I know we
were talking about him a little bit
earlier and just not having as much
volume with Sam darnold but got to give
credit where credit's due Donald has
been good at targeting DJ Moore this
year and we've actually gotten three
usable top 24 performances out of these
four games he's been under Center so
there is a low floor truly a zero point
floor for anyone involved in this
Panthers passing game but compared to
Great Dolce it's on a Broncos team at
this point that who knows what kind of
motivation they're going to have without
Hackett in week 17 and Tyler Boyd who is
always going to be the number three
option in that passing game with Jason
Higgins Give me DJ Moore
all right guys two more sits to go over
and then we'll get to all your start
stick questions here Michael Pittman
Indianapolis Colts will be a recommended
sit for me this week if you guys
unfortunately had to witness the Nick
Foles experience on Monday night was not
pretty but honestly this passing game
and seasoned as a whole hasn't been
pretty for Michael Pittman I mean since
week one just one touchdown one freaking
touchdown since week one reminder it's
week 17 right now that is objectively
not good and he's only had one game with
more than 75 receiving yards since week
one as well so man you look at that
Colts offense Pittman has a big weak one
Jonathan Taylor goes for 160 in a tuddy
how times have changed that's not even
getting to Matt Ryan so hey we did see
Pittman have a team High seven targets
with falls under Center but I don't know
about you guys I wouldn't be surprised
at all if Jeff's Saturday makes that
switch to Sam Ellinger sooner rather
than later and sadly that could be an
even worse offensive environment for
Pitman to deal with so maybe he does get
one of those volume games I mean we saw
in that crazy Vikings come back he found
his way to get 10 catches 60 yards and
for PPR you will take that so all these
start sets are relative if it's Pitman
versus you know I don't mean to keep
trashing too too out well here but
someone like that then yes I will be
taking Michael Pittman but overall on
the week just my wide receiver 29 I'd
start guys like DJ Moore Jerry Judy Juju
Smith Schuster Christian Kirk Brandon
ayok and many more ahead of him and
let's close out my top 10 starts and
sets with Raiders tight end Darren
Waller and I'll be honest guys I had him
on this list even before finding out the
news about Derek Carr mostly because of
that volume issue if you actually look
past his two decent performances back
from injury he's not even running a
route on 60 percent of the offenses drop
backs they clearly are trying to ease
him back into action and with them being
pretty much nothing to play for over
these past two weeks technically you
know a one percent chance of them making
the playoffs but I think we know the
Raiders aren't anticipating that
happening by benching Derek Carr in the
first place Darren Waller unfortunately
is just a complimentary pass game option
in a passing game that we're looking at
being downright terrible with Jared
Stidham under Center so waller for me
just my tight end 14 behind coca Met
taysom Hill Noah fan pot frying with
Tyler Higby and many more
and with that everyone let's jump into
personalized fantasy advice presented by
State Farm where the personal price plan
is all about creating a price just for
you send in the start sets we got some
time it's a great day to be great I just
want to help you guys win these fantasy
championships so from ptb Higby or Kemet
in Half Point PPR gonna have to go with
Tyler Higby the problems we've seen with
Tyler higbee this season happen when the
Rams have used him more so as a you know
six offensive lineman kept him in the
pass block since Baker Mayfield has been
under Center he leads the team in
targets and his snap rates are back to
touching almost 100 percent give me
Higby from seaback and Camara or Acres
man I am going to have to go with Cam
acres in this it's wild wild time to be
alive but first of all we got Kamara
missing practice with a quad and
personal reasons not sure what's going
on there and even he's wondering why
he's not being used more so on third
down so at this point Alvin Kamara
averaging career low marks in PPR points
per game from purely receiving
production meanwhile cam makers 15 plus
touches with a snap rate north of 70
percent and three of his last four games
hey credit to you man for making the
championship seemingly asked me this
question with acres and Kamara on the
squad give me acres in this one
from kpat 12 most likely to have
historical fantasy Championship
performance yeah this is a good one guys
I actually took some time to go through
some of the most you know memorable
fantasy performances and tweeted out
here earlier so remember from 2010 to
2020 you know we didn't have the 18-week
season yet so I took the week 60
performances from then in the week 17
from last year and my God we had the
sixth touchdown game from Alvin Kamara
when he was letting us all know in 2020
Jamar Chase going absolutely nuclear
last season and before that girly
thielen A.B saquon and even Mr throw up
the X himself Dez Bryant going off all
the way back in 2012. so most likely
just a boom in this one I feel like it
has to go to that Lions Bears game
somewhere because we do have again the
highest game total of the week a lions
defense that hasn't been able to stop
pretty much anyone all season long and a
Bears defense that wasn't all that great
to start the year and then they
basically sold their only two good
players in roquan Smith and Robert Quinn
I'm gonna go with the Sun God himself
Amman ra Saint Brown we'll say 10
catches 125 yards not one but two
touchdowns go get him Sun God
from g-clips Jared Goff or Dak Prescott
I'm actually leaning just slightly
towards Jared Goff here so someone that
we've seen give us some honestly Great
Performances particularly in domes and
that's the wild part with Jared Goff
guys I was looking through some of these
stats and kudos to the men last week not
one not two but three touchdowns so
Shane zylstra of all freaking people
playing against the Panthers Outdoors
but in domes with the lines here over
the past two seasons 35 touchdowns
versus 10 picks Outdoors 10 touchdowns
versus three picks now I understand he's
played more games indoors but you know
PFF passing grade goes up by 12 points
yards per attempt is higher he's been
more accurate higher passer rating Jared
Goffin domes awfully hard to compete
with especially when you're facing that
aforementioned Bears defense that hasn't
been able to stop pretty much anyone for
the better part of the second half of
this season
from Magicka fee do I played Josh Jacobs
or jarek McKinnon you know good problem
to have but it's going to be Josh Jacobs
man still very much leads the NFL in
rushing and has a career-high mark in
receiving errors in his own right this
season so I know McKinnon has been
crushing it but as we saw last week very
much so two running backfield in Kansas
City give me the true Workhorse and Josh
Jacobs
from remix 84 Naji Singletary or James
Cook gonna be nausea Harris for me again
just comes down to that sweet sweet
volume with Singletary and James Cook
continue to see them not necessarily
cancel each other out but let's face it
you know that Chicago Bears game not
exactly seeing bills usually attack
defenses in that manner meanwhile Naji
Harris the Steelers historically all too
willing to feed their over the rb1
whoever it is 20 plus touches give me
Naji
from sportswiz Goddard or ayok at the
flex as long as Debo Samuel stays out
which it does look like it could be
another week there started off the week
with the DMP I will continue to go with
Brandon ayok here so Dallas Goddard very
good obviously and right he's the top
five tight end for me this week but is a
top 20 wide receiver so give me ayuk
from it's the most uh Kirk or Jared Goff
gonna be gone with Jared Goff here
credit to Kirk Cousins here you know
three straight top five fantasy finishes
really coming on strong but going up in
Lambo against the Packers defense that
has given him a few problems over the
years similar to Jared Goff we have seen
the best version of cousins indoors
compared to Outdoors giving me golf and
was shaping up to be the shootout of the
week against the Bears
from B Garcia Evans or Romeo Dobbs it'll
be a little more interesting if we do
actually see uh Christian Watson get
ruled out but I did see that he got in a
limited practice with that hip injury on
Thursday so with that in mind this
offense they're just rotating guys
behind Christian Washington and Alan
Lazard so if we had a full role knew
exactly that Romeo Dobbs was gonna be a
number one guy okay I think it could be
a reasonably reasonably close question
but for now give me Mike Evans and it's
one of those things where it's weird to
Hype up a guy by talking about you know
the lack of success he's had or whatever
but truly 11 straight games without a
touchdown from Mike Evans has anyone
ever been more due for this guy maybe
he's been waiting for week 17 to save
his best for last for all those faithful
fantasy managers still somehow alive
with Evans on the squad
from Nathan candile Ingram or Dalton
Schultz that's a good question my friend
let me pull off my handy dandy ranks
from pff.com and I am just barely
leaning towards Dalton Schultz here and
my thing with this when you look at the
Cowboys offense especially now without
Tony Pollard it does seem like they're
going to have to throw the ball to have
a bunch of success against the Tennessee
Titans I mean when you look across the
league it's the Titans it's the Ravens
and who is the other mostly pass funnel
defense Titans Ravens yeah those are two
of them so Tennessee as we've seen
throughout the year so good against the
Run they basically Force offenses throw
the ball and Dalton Schultz as long as
Dak has been under Center fantastic at
getting volume weekend and week out and
there should be more than ever again
without Tony Pollard also operating in
those underneath and intermediate areas
of the field so give me Dalton Schultz
just buy a hair Houston I know you know
they haven't exactly been a good team
this year they play some teams more
competitively here over the past three
weeks but Houston really much better
against the past than the Run overall
from sok 22 start 2 between Chris alave
Zach moss and Bam Knight I lean towards
the running backs in that equation whip
bam Knight having Mike White back under
Center also facing a Seahawks defense
bottom five against the position in ppro
points per game and then with Zach Moss
we're also looking at 20 plus touches so
Chris I mean most likely I mean we'll
see what happens with the game script
but he did have over 70 of the offensive
snaps last week obviously they weren't
able to say uh super competitive but I
would say 15 plus Touches for Moss is on
the table and the crystalave we have
seen teams most notably the Chiefs and
JuJu Smith Schuster occasionally ease
guys back into action even after coming
back from a con from a hamstring or
concussion so one of those things with
the larvae not entirely sure how healthy
he is giving the two running backs that
I am more confident in their overall
volume
from Nick house picked two acres Sanders
and fournette if it's uh if it's
standard scoring then all of a sudden I
think we could go with acres and Sanders
but otherwise give me acres and Leonard
fournette again it's this shocked me
guys as someone that's even watched the
dude play all year to see Leonard
fournette top 12 running back and for
PPR not only overall but also on a per
game basis wild time to be alive and
then McCann makers again just really
having more of a future he's having the
featured role now that we thought he was
going to have to start the season so I
get it first 12 weeks absolutely
terrible time to be in the cam makers
business things have started turn around
for both him and this Rams offense
though ever since Baker Mayfield got
there hey Alan should I start corduro
Patterson or AJ Dylan gotta be AJ Dylan
and it pains me again you know long time
president of the CPAP fan club but
unfortunately with Patterson he has been
leaped on the death chart by Tyler
algier and it's not even just that Avery
Williams is out there getting more
targets than cordarrell Patterson I
don't get it but it doesn't matter what
I get we just have to read the usage and
go from there so give me AJ Dylan from
Trent Hammond Tyler Boyd or Jacoby Myers
oh that's a tough one if we see Devonte
Parker get back for the Patriots I am
going to lean towards Tyler Boyd here
just the overall passing environment I
want to say Mac Jones has led this
offense to over 225 passing yards one
time in the last 10 weeks so yes there
have been stretches where to Kobe Myers
has been getting fed targets and
everything but coming off a week where
it ended up being Kendrick born as a
featured receiver Nelson aglers had a
good game over the past few weeks a bit
too crowded for me in an offense that
doesn't have all that much upside in the
first place give me the guy that's at
least in an offense led by Joe burrow
that you can wrap your mind around
having a true boom performance
a couple more Stony ayuk Gallup or
Cortland Sutton I will be going with
Brandon ayuk in that group again without
Debo Samuel I know over these last two
weeks it's been George Kittle getting
the multi touchdown games and all that
but we've seen this happen and offense
is like the eagles for example
especially earlier in the year where aj
Brown Devonte Smith Dallas Goddard it's
tough for a run for his offense to keep
all three of their really talented pass
catchers putting up consistently
high-end production week in and week out
so again if you just zoom back a little
bit and continue to look at Brandon ayok
as the featured wide receiver in an
offense that's been able to routinely
freeze past that 30 point mark even with
Brock Purdy under Center I will take
ayuk and finally guys Bay 11 we got
Devonte Adams ayak or DJ Shark look I
don't want to be a complete slave to the
you know start your studs mindset but
it's Devonte Adams start your freaking
studs there might not be a more subtly
wide receiver in the NFL than Devonte so
yes it is rough with Jared Stidham under
Center and honestly Adams has been
slumping least relative to him over
these past three weeks but if there is
ever a time for the Raiders just to
force feed the guy who is complaining
now about car getting benched in the
first place you would think it would be
in this spot so with atoms I just think
even if the efficiency is down compared
to guys like ayak and DJ Chuck we could
talk we could be talking about him
having honestly double the amount of
targets that those guys are going to see
so that's gonna wrap up another edition
of BR Fantasy Live I appreciate you guys
tuning in throughout the seasons
hopefully been on some assistance and
the rest is up to you set those lineups
go bring home that Championship gold my
goodness it is a great day to be great
so thanks again for tuning in to BR
Fantasy Live I'm Ian Hardison until next
time take care everybody